[Musique]
bernard henri lévy dit de lui qu'il est
nationaliste et raciste
eric dupond-moretti explique qu'il est
négationniste bruno le maire précise
révisionnistes et christophe castaner
ajoute sexiste anne hidalgo et dégoûté
jusqu'à la nausée jean marc borello
porte parole de la république en marge
brute en lui un virus est ce qu'il fait
le président la religion est ce qui peut
être président moi je pense qu'il peut
être président moi je pense que je
pourrais je pense donc rouler pour le
futur vainqueur je peux être je pense
qui peut être président parce que ce
qu'il a très bien compris et d'ailleurs
ce il le dit mais je le dis aussi depuis
des années c'est que en 2022 ça sera pas
une élection présidentielle ça sera la
bataille de france et pour la france
c'est pour ça que vous avez choisi ce
jour précisément en hommage à iéna mais
en hommage à napoléon pour déclarer
votre candidature sur notre antenne vous
êtes vous êtes habile mais ça ne rend
pas trop moche et que je viens de dire
le président a joué au foot en faveur de
la fondation des hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france ce qui nous a permis
de découvrir des bandeaux de chaînes
infos qu'on n'aurait jamais imaginé voir
de notre vivant
emmanuel macron mouiller le maillot
macron short
de macron
macro égalise
de maquereaux
moins de dix minutes de jeu penalty
pour une frappe ni à droite ni à gauche
met en place
[Musique]
et jouer des jouets
n'y a pas photo y'a pas photo allez
allez allez
les festives et le degré sur lui
je vois dans la posture du président de
la république un sportif il se tient
dans un vestiaire avant un match comme
un sportif un président jeune s'est
beaucoup entraîné ses proches disent
qu'il est revenue très vite vous savez
comme on dit c'est un président qui
physiquement affûté est-ce que tu
connais notre chef invité 3g l'occasion
de manger deux fois à vos desserts votre
restaurant vous savez promu maître à
l'elysée tu avais goûté quoi toi petit
assortiment de desserts mais avec a des
goûts assez franc pour moi qu'elle a du
caractère et c'était le meilleur
souvenir j'ai gardé dans le restaurant
le soul le 93 qui mangent des gâteaux de
l'elysée c'est magnifique
on aime vous êtes à côté de cette jeune
femme tout en dignité qui est magnifique
là à côté de vous et que vous voulez non
mais pardonnez moi
regardant dans les yeux qu'elle ne fait
partie ni vendues aux françaises ont
ordonné mois cette jeune femme pour vous
ne fait pas partie de l'identité
française c'est la france est la france
de la fin de la mission l'accoutrement
de fait n'a pas été probant
j'aime l'industrie parce que c'est un
des rares endroits au 20e siècle on
trouve encore de la magie la magie de
l'atelier où on ne distingue pas le
cadre de l'ouvrier ou ne distingue pas
l'apprenti de celui qui a 30 ans
d'expérience ou ne distingue pas celui
qui est né en france il y à 40 ans et
c'est lui qui est arrivé par l'accident
de ceux d'une vie il y a quelques jours
a raconté une fois benjamin qui était
parti en week-end
las vegas prendre comme ça c'est à dire
hier las vegas le fait en fait il a joué
au casino aidé à gagner une énorme somme
d'argent
c'était
monaco et il a gagné une énorme somme
d'argent et cette énorme somme d'argent
et dak lak et en un week-end lorsque qui
va sur une ligne de production
c'est pas une punition c'est pour ton
pays c'est pour la magie et c'est ça que
vous pouvez rendre impossible d'accord
ouais ben majid origine la magie lui
jiabao divergents qui font les trois
huit je pense qu'ils vont être
complètement d'accord avec elle quand je
vous dis que les politiques ça va pas
fort
il ya 15 ans c'était il ya 15 ans avec
100 trains de son train de vie c'est de
l'argent qui tombait du ciel comme midi
il a voulu faire plaisir à tout le monde
et la lâcher en à peine une semaine sept
cent cinquante mille euros
[Applaudissements]
à l'hégémonie moi aller
je me laissais c'est un peu falic
[Musique]
oui c'est à quoi tu as pensé en 116 à un
ami
alors c'est quoi cette ligne d'âge
comprends pas c'est le monde
pour faciliter la dégustation
et comme on dit en bourgogne bon appétit
alors ce soir et personne vous avez fait
la blague de remplacer un verre d'eau
par un verre d'eau de vie non sapers non
non il ya ya ya que josé pour faire ça
et il s'y risque pas s'y risque pas la
balle est dans mon camp j'ai j'en ai une
avance sur lui il souhaitait un tête à
tête avec un bison ils ont
malheureusement vu leur rêve exaucé ces
visiteurs d'un parc animalier du québec
ont vu d'un peu trop près le bovidé les
touristes n'ont pas respecté les
consignes de sécurité en voulons nourrir
l'animal de 800 kilos celui ci est resté
coincé la tête dans le véhicule pendant
30 minutes si la vidéo ne montre pas
comment le bison est ressorti il n'y a
pas eu de blessé mais les visiteurs
imprudent resteront à coup sûr marqué
par cet effet boeuf
pareil que pour elle
je vais m'énerver
[Musique]
tu as jeté les folles
voilà
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu
as préféré une ajouté mme bel que nous
le présenter je fais d'habitude de très
belles choses et que je suis très carré
dans tout ce que je fais or quand je
fais quelque chose qui me plaît pas ça
m'énerve malheur à ce point là sam est
montée d'un coup et quand c'est ça je
réfléchis plus c'est mon tempérament tu
l'as mis dans la poubelle le gâteau
malheureusement on va pas le goûter il
ya des choses qui soit certainement
bonne on aurait pu en discuter mais là
tu nous donnes pas la chance d'en
discuter moi ça fait dix ans je fais le
meilleur pâtissier j'ai jamais vu ça
sera envoyé à josé garcia de notre
alegre compliments l'équipe de c'est à
vous allez on voit l'image
[Rires]
[Musique]
m